les
une route chômage sous un ciel 30 il est
cependant vrai
beaucoup de chemin
je pousse la grille
et soudain
une grande maison au bout d'une allée
effectivement une grande maison tout
abandonner puis sur la pente une petite
pancarte où l'on a écrit
à louer
car il
marc à jamais
levante s'est levé
hélas au premier ce volet qui pas de
faire toujours par se relaient grince un
cachet à prague où tu marais premier
mais un jour
un jour quand même ouf je t attends du
dip ou jusqu'au petit matin ce coup
tu n'es pas vos désirs les mois ont
passé
et malgré pas seulement
je t'attends
beau
à
le
cas
et
à jamais
je souffrirais
procédure
je
rajouter
ça
non